Trojan Horses get their name from
a tale from the Trojan Wars.
It is said that the Greeks wanted to
enter the well fortified city of Troy.
Rather than launching a direct assault
at the city and suffering huge losses,
they devised a wooden horse and they
hid their soldiers inside the horse.
Then the left the horse out side
the gates of Troy as a gift.
The Trojans thought the horse
as a gift to acknowledge that
the Greeks had been defeated.
And so they brought the horse
into the city of Troy.
At night, the Greek soldiers
hidden in the horse came out.
And they let their fellow
soldiers waiting outside the city
come in as well.
As a result, the Greek soldiers
passed all of Troy's defenses, and
destroyed the city, and won the war.
In the context of malware,
a Trojan horse is a piece
malicious code embedded in a utility
program that a user will run frequently.
That is, when a user runs this
useful program, the malicious code,
or the Trojan horse is also executing.
An example of a Trojan Horse is a login
program that performs key logging
meaning stealing user login and
password and
pass along such confidential
information to an internet server.
The login program will still allow the
user to log in by calling the real login
subroutine because otherwise
the user would notice.
Many malicious browser extensions or
also perform key logging and
phishing, in addition to
some useful functions and
these are the latest
examples of Trojan Horses.